president Trump's medical experts say
they're seeing signs that social
distancing and other efforts to slow the
spread of the corona virus have been
working but they warn the next few weeks
are critical
they say Americans must not get
complacent yesterday the president said
he thinks the country will reopen though
sooner rather than later and we could do
it in phases we can go to some areas
which you know some areas are much less
affected than others but it would be
nice to be able to open with a big bang
and open up our country or certainly
most of our country and I think we're
going to do that soon it would certainly
be nice dr. Anthony Fauci is a member of
the White House coronavirus task force
and he's also the top infectious disease
doctor at the National Institutes of
Health dr. Fauci good morning so we just
heard that these models showing death
projections in the United States have
fortunately been revised downward but
that's only one model what are you
seeing
among all the models and what does it
mean for this reopening potentially of
the country well you know the models as
I've often said are as good as the
assumptions that you put into the models
and those are something sometimes when
you tweak them a little they really
change the the range of the kinds of
projections that you've heard remember
we were talking about 100,000 to 200,000
deaths what's happening is that we are
doing a very good job on mitigation on
the physical separation the adherence to
the guidelines and as new data comes in
what you do you integrate that data into
the model to modify the model and that's
why you're seeing those projections
coming down somewhat that's good news
but the thing we have to be careful of
that we don't then take that good news
to think that we might be able to pull
back a bit we've got to continue in many
respects to redouble our efforts at the
mitigation of physical separation in
order to keep those numbers down and
hopefully even get them lower than what
you've heard recently so dr. Fauci let's
talk about that redoubling of our
efforts because what a lot of Americans
are thinking right now is okay so I've
made it to April I'm going to go through
the spring what about the
summer virtually everybody in this
country has some kind of thing planned
for this summer can they expect to go
forward with those plans or will we
still be in some sort of a shelter in
place or a lockdown condition you know
it looks like things are going to be
improving if you look at the curves that
we talked about we often talk about
flattening the curve and then getting
around the corner and coming down if in
fact we see that and it'll be
differential in different parts of the
country I mean New York City the
terrible ordeal that they've gone
through is very different from some of
the places in the middle of the country
or in the mountain regions so when you
say get back to normal it's not going to
be a light switch that you turn on and
off it's going to be differential and
gradual depending upon where you are and
where the burden of infection is but the
bottom line of it all is that we see
looking forward it is very likely that
we will progress towards the steps
towards normalization as we get to the
end of this 30 days and I think that's
going to be a good time to look and see
how quickly can we make that move to try
and normalize but hopefully and
hopefully by the time we get to the
summer we will have taken many steps in
that direction so doctor foul sure when
you start talking about that progress
toward normalization can you envision a
summer at this point based on the models
where people are going back to beaches
people are going to baseball games
weddings are happening reunions are
happening is that in the cards right now
it can be in the cards and and I say
that with some caution because as I said
when we do that when we pull back and
try to open up the country as we often
use that terminology we have to be
prepared that when the infection starts
to rear their heads again that we have
it in place a very aggressive and
effective way to identify isolate
contact trace and make sure we don't
have those spikes that we see now so the
answer to your question is yes if we do
the things that we need to do to prevent
the resurgence
are you personally expecting to take a
summer vacation somewhere other than
Washington DC this summer well you're
talking to the wrong person I don't take
vacations I'm just I just want to look
at what we have in front of us right now
I'm not thinking about vacations well
let's talk about one other thing that
that you say you don't think anyone
should be doing and I presume that means
yourself as well and that's shaking
hands I think a lot of people heard that
yesterday and they thought to themselves
as you as you said yourself sounds crazy
we're never shaking hands again walk
walk us through your thinking there no
no I I did it almost a little bit
tongue-in-cheek but not really there was
a bit of reality to that what I really
meant is that we really now need to be
aware of because it is hit us smack in
the face that respiratory infections
particularly brand new ominous
respiratory infections like we're going
through right now clearly spread very
much not only by droplets but by people
touching their face shaking hands and
that's the reason why we talk about
washing hands so often I don't think in
reality that we're gonna all of a sudden
never again shake hands but I think I
threw that out there to get people to
start thinking much more about personal
hygiene and the and the in the way that
impacts the spread of a really deadly
infection like we're going through right
now all right dr. Fauci well I hope you
and I can meet face to face sometime
soon and I will shake your hand if I get
that opportunity appreciate you being on
with us this morning yeah looking
forward to it take care all right